hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast understanding and inhibiting
horizontal gene transfer of antibiotic
resistance it is presented by Allison
lopat can pH D a postdoctoral scholar at
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology MIT and the Broad Institute
of MIT and Harvard I am Judy or Oracle
Everts and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. lope Atkin I
will now turn the presentation over to
her
or cause so thank you all so much for
having me today I'm going to talk to you
about understanding and inhibiting
horizontal gene transfer of antibiotic
resistance
specifically how we can use mathematical
modeling as a tool to understand these
bacterial processes
as we've all heard many times either to
the news or over the past few days even
antibiotic resistance is a growing
global threat the rate I which bacteria
acquire resistance to our available
antibiotics if it significantly faster
than the rate by which new antibiotics
are being developed without drastic
intervention it's actually been
estimated that mortality from infectious
diseases is going to skyrocket
potentially reaching almost 20 million
people by the year 2050 becoming the
leading global cause of death
now that Syria can acquire genetic
resistance by two mechanisms first
spontaneous genetic mutations arise
creating populations with the natural
variability by chance any one of these
mutations can confer increased
resistance to the drugs
depending on where it is and what
exactly that mutation is doing
alternatively horizontal gene transfer
enables the non genealogical
transmission of resistance from one
bacteria to another
of these two mechanisms HGT is by far
the dominant mode responsible for
spreading antibiotic resistance
unlike genetic mutations which take a
long and slow process of stepwise
accumulation over time in order to be
clinically relevant although that's not
always the case
HGT can bypass this denovo evolution
process by spreading pre-existing
resistance genes across very wide
phylogenetic death
and this enables distantly related
species to share the same set of fully
functional genes
now HGT occurred by three main
mechanisms conjugation transformation
and transection
today I'm specifically talking about one
of these three which is the conjugation
of positive DNA
for those unfamiliar plasmids are
circular self-replicating element to DNA
carried by bacteria which is separate
from their chromosomal DNA
when plasmid conjugation refers to the
transfer of this DNA from a donor cell
to a recipient cell through direct cell
to cell context generating what's called
a transcontinent
and the reason I'm talking about
conjugation is because this is release
to be the dominant mode of HGT
responsible for clinical is this makes
sense
because plasmas are highly prevalent it
has very broad host ranges which means
that they can stabili exist in very
diverse species
and spasms are known to encode one or
multiple antibiotic resistance genes
what disease is that a sensitive cells
can become multi drug-resistant in a
matter of minutes
once HGT occurs movement at the
population level basically transfers
bacteria across geographical boundaries
if your new species can come into
contact with one another in the
environment further Scott energies
through additional h duty
this dynamic process can be to be global
dissemination of antibiotic resistance
perhaps best exemplified by the rise and
spread of ndm-1
which is a they more recently discovered
resistance gene and that's what this map
is showing you on the right hand side of
this slide
and then one confers resistance to our
very last resort data last hand drugs
and this map is showing you it's spread
over the past ten years so you can see
that it only took five years for it to
reach almost every single continent on a
single case
IBM one has since been identified in a
variety of different species it's known
to be located on a conjugate able
plasmid that can carry anywhere up to 14
or more additional antibiotic resistant
genes
so that should I have been engaging in
horizontal gene transfer from
million-a-year so why is it that only
now we're seeing the rampant increase in
the spread of resistance well while HGT
is an ease for rapid evolution but
through these subsequent ecological
interactions driving the population
dynamics and this is accelerating the
process
okay so then what a population dynamics
see well specifically the overviews and
misuse of antibiotics have imposed on D
selection pressures on that cereal
population
this gives resistant cells an unfair
competitive advantage enabling them to
out-compete their sensitive neighbors
that are unable to as easily withstand
the drugs
but resistance cells may only have that
competitive advantage in the presence of
the drugs so in many cases actually
resistant plasmids can be costly to the
cell
because it requires again in many cases
a little bit more metabolic effort for
the cell to carry that plasmid express
these genes off of that plasmid
especially when you compare that to the
same exact cells but without the plasmid
so it's plasmid free counterpart
so for these examples for a plasma
that's costly when we remove the
antibiotic this changes the ecological
dynamics and this tips that ecological
scale back into the favor of the
sensitive population
and in theory this enables sensitive
cells to displace their resistance
counterparts your competition
eventually reversing resistance
so reversing resistance is a fundamental
goal for efforts like antibiotic
stewardship
efforts like this aim to promote more
appropriate antibiotic usage at its core
the premise that reducing antibiotic use
will facilitate reverse and resistance
is based on this very notion that I just
described that we can take advantage of
ecological dynamics and return bacteria
to the sensitive state
unfortunately reducing antibiotic use
has seen mixed outcomes in the clinic
while some operational aspects have
benefited some stewardship efforts such
as reducing unnecessary prescribing or
costs associated for the improper use of
antibiotics
in many cases the impact on the
prevalence of resistance has been
inconclusive
for almost every example where we may
have seen a large reduction in
resistance there's another example where
resistance to decrease only slightly and
then stagnated or in some situations
doesn't even decrease at all
for example trimethoprim was
discontinued in the UK in the early
1990s and e-coli cells are still still
being to have around 45 to 50 percent
time a supreme resistance at 30 years
later
similarly evidence shows that an area's
view antibiotic-free
prevalence of resistance is just as high
as in areas that use antibiotics
frequently and so overall this has
resulted in the pretty much general
consensus in the literature which is
that simply simply reducing or
minimizing antibiotic use alone will not
be sufficient to reverse resistance
and so we need to find another way but
in order to do that we need to
understand why
so to this end it's been proposed that
underlying evolutionary dynamics are
actually contributing to maintaining
antibiotic resistance even in the
absence of active selection
for example even if a plasmid is costly
to the cells
and it should be out competed by this
process that I just described it's
possible that conjugation itself could
act as a mechanism to counteract this
process
conjugation could replenish plasmas is
the population almost like a parasite
however bacterial populations are
extremely complex
they consist of simultaneous
evolutionary mechanisms like HGT or
conjugation along with ecological
dynamics like competition and selection
and both of these contribute to either
promoting maintaining or even reversing
resistance
and since all of these processes occur
on similar timescales ecological and
evolutionary dynamics are tightly
coupled potentially even feeding back on
one another which historically has made
experimentally demonstrating or
understanding the role of HGT on plasmid
persistence very difficult to
conclusively determine
this is especially prohibitive for
natural vascular communities that have
many other intricate levels of
interaction and so overall a lack of
quantification and fundamental
understanding has made it challenging to
determine the role of HGT on spreading
and maintaining antibiotic resistance in
complex bacterial communities
and I just want to emphasize that this
understanding is critical so that we can
develop effective complementary
strategies for effectively reversing
antibiotic resistance
now the
populations are so complex this type of
question lends itself extremely well to
assistance and synthetic biology
approach
this framework is built upon an
iterative build test refinement cycles
where models are constructed and used to
generate predictions these predictions
can be tested in an experimental setting
and the results of those experiments can
be used to update the model so on and so
forth
on a spectrum of relevance modeling is
extremely well defined but it may not
always be that biologically meaningful
in comparison when natural systems are
most relevant there are also the most
challenging to interpret meaningful
conclusions from since they offer little
to no controllable variables and so in
this context synthetic biology falls
somewhere in the middle
synthetic biology allows us to design
and construct biological systems de novo
to realize the Civic function it is
ideal for justice purpose of
investigating complex dynamics as we can
use synthetic biology to design systems
with controllable and tunable biological
behaviors for example I can engineer a
synthetic conjugation where I can
specifically turn it on or off which
gives me the ideal experimental control
over HGT
while it does have an element of
construction which makes it somewhat
more artificial than the natural system
measurements from a synthetic systems
are constrained by these biological
processes and this provides the perfect
context to estimate relevant parameters
so today I'm going to walk you through
the process of assistance to synthetic
biology and back again and I'm hoping
that you can walk away with a greater
appreciation of the utility that
modeling can offer for providing real
biological insights that might even be
clinically relevant
status to build a new model
briefly a population dynamics model
fundamentally answers how the population
changes as a function of two specific SS
the first is biological processes
these form the structure of the model
equations and includes or accounts for
both the ecological and evolutionary
mechanisms
the second is the environmental
condition
and this or the environmental conditions
like antibiotic treatment are
specifically captured in the parameters
of the model
now the model I'm going to present is
going to start simple and it's going to
grow in complexity and it aims to
capture conjugation dynamics as a
function of antibiotic collection for
the ultimate goal of understanding how
HGT contributes
to maintaining resistance
so to start out with here's a simple
three population system donors and
recipients each carry unique resistance
markers kanamycin and chloramphenicol
respectively upon conjugation kanamycin
resistance is transferred to the
recipient cell generating a trance
conjugant that is now resistant to both
drugs
video gives you an idea of what the
resulting population dynamics look like
you
you
so what you just saw for donors and
recipients that were mixed together and
grown for four hours
for four hours I introduce high
concentrations of both Panama's and
influence on a call
that's when you saw most of the cells be
killed but then you notice the emergence
of a third population that third
population appears yellow by eye that's
because the channel myosin resistance is
also on a plasma tagged with green
fluorescence the yellow is simply the
special overlap of red and green
fluorescence but specifically those are
the trans conjugates that can now
dominate the population
you
so to model this simplified scenario
there are basically two main processes
that contributed to those observed
dynamics
first is the relative fitness of each
population this depends on the growth
rate and this change is dependent on the
environment that they're growing in so
for example since I used two antibiotics
that select for the trans conjugant
you could clearly see the trans
conjugates had a huge Fitness advantage
while the other to the parent cells were
inhibited had I use only one antibiotics
only one of the parents would have been
inhibited
the other two populations would have
been significantly fitter and we may
have seen a mixture at the end of the
experiment
and I use no antibiotics we may have
never seen the emergence of trans
continence at all because both parents
are likely lightly more fit than the
trans conjugant because that cell has to
express two different resistance genes
compared to the parents which only has
to express one
in other words the benefit of carrying a
plasmid is entirely dictated by the
function and encodes and whether or not
it is useful in the particular
environments
so that's the first that's the primary a
biological process the second one is the
rate of gene transfer itself that's the
conjugation efficiency
so combining all of this together gives
rise to a simple diagrammatic model
representation of conjugation dynamics
we have three populations the donor
recipient and the trans conjugant these
three populations grow at different
rates the donor transfers a plasmatic to
new recipient at a rate I'm calling it a
to see here that's not really important
this is the conjugation efficiency
and each population is uniquely
resistant to one drug but sensitive to
the other one analogous to the video
this means that depending on the
concentration of one or both antibiotics
the relative fitness of the populations
will change
so I just wanted to emphasize that you
could probably build a model that's
capable of capturing pretty much
anything you want
that doesn't necessarily mean it's
biologically so constructing equations
that are biologically relevant is the
first and most important step to ensure
that a model can provide useful insight
into your system
a set of equations described
mathematically the changes in population
members through defined processes such
as growth death the conjugation exchange
each parameter represents is the Civic
biological process and each parameter
can be experimentally estimated
overall the strength of the model depend
on constraints imposed by both by those
parameters in other words how good are
your parameter estimates
be more parameters that can be
accurately measured be more relevant the
model becomes
for more free parameters there are that
cannot be estimating the more difficult
it is to validate the model and the more
meaning is lost from it now this model
in particular is great because there are
only four parameters it's very simple
and each of these parameters can be
readily experimental II estimated
it's important to make sure that the way
parameters are quantified experimental
II is consistent with the interpretation
of the biological process it represents
in the model
at the population level for example
conjugation can be approximated as a
simple by molecular reaction between a
donor recipient and the resulting trans
conjugates
so this framework you can easily write
the mathematical expression for
contribution kinetics
which gives us some intuition and to the
conjugation efficiency which represents
the rate constant of this reaction
under the assumption that the time
window of conjugation is short and this
both R and D or the terms are roughly
constant then we can solve an explicit
form for the conjugation efficiency
which as you can see depends on all
three populations and the time at which
you let them conjugate
all that's to say but to accurately
quantify conjugation efficiency as the
rate constant we assume it is we need to
measure it experimentally under
conditions that most closely and
accurately meet these assumptions
that means measuring conjugation using a
protocol that enables measurements of
all T populations over a minimal time
window and with negligible growth
and so using a protocol that does need
these provisions
I activated the conjugation efficiencies
for a broad range of clinically relevant
and instead of cosmas and that I'm
showing you on the right hand side here
and you can see they vary in magnitude
but all of them represent the rate
constant of this reaction itself
this is particularly important because
an accurate parameter estimates can lead
to improper data interpretation or
inconclusive results
example in the literature some suggested
widely antibiotics specifically increase
the rate of conjugation
however the conjugation efficiency
measurements were not rigorously defined
they occurred over a long time intervals
and there were significant growth of the
parents this creates a bias due to
selection and it doesn't necessarily
represents the true rate constant of the
conjugation reaction
instead when conjugation is measured
using our definition that I'm describing
here
with matching experimental positions
than meet those assumptions where we
found it is cut off prep defraud at the
x-axis of the figure on the right is
increasing antibiotic concentration each
of the colors represents one of ten
different drugs and the y-axis is
normalized conjugation efficiency and so
what we saw was that for all of these
ten different drugs antibiotics cutting
negligible influence on the conjugation
efficiency in stark contrast to the
established dogma
we also show that this is true for
clinically relevant positives Islam
so that's one example similarly growth
estimates and easily determined by
fitting exponential functions to
bacterial growth curve and this is going
to use to determine I didn't ask the
meant of how costly a specific positive
as long as we use this to back on shoes
and we're really looking at a plasmid
and positive free counterparts then the
ratio between growth rates of a plasma
Tori cell and its large entry version
can accurately estimate that Fitness
burden so in the street on the right the
extractor to be again antibiotics the
y-axis is the ratio for this represents
how burdensome that positive you can see
that without an antibiotic that plasma
is costly to the cell
and as you start to increase the
antibiotics the relative fitness changes
of the function of the environmental
advantage provided by antibiotic
selection
okay so if your model is formulated
correctly on the subsequent parameter
estimates were all done accurately then
you should be able to generate simple
model predictions that can be readily
validated
so for example if antibiotics do not
change the conjugation efficiency itself
how do we selection environments
influence the overall conjugation
dynamics
so we investigated that using the model
from left to right of these figures I'm
showing you four different selection
environments or simulated based on
different combinations of growth rates
each of which has a realistic
counterpart of kanamycin and
chloramphenicol combination the y-axis
is the percentage of trans conjugant
and the x-axis is the antibiotic
concentration and as you can see her
modeling predicts diverse collection
environment will result in drastically
different conjugation dynamics when this
ranges from constant to monotonically
decreasing biphasic so on and so forth
while we investigate this experimental
II we could easily validate the model
prediction and we showed that the
selection Dynamis indeed could entirely
account for the conjugation dynamics
this also validates a constant
conjugation efficiency since the results
would have looked significantly
different had that efficiency depended
on antibiotic concentration
interesting way
these results suggest that antibiotics
and our intuitively promote or suppress
the emergencies of trans competence
depending on the selection rooms
when I mean though that is in some cases
higher antibiotics would even be better
than no antibiotics at all and so for
that I'm looking at the second panel at
high antibiotics you can see that it's
decreased compared to be starting you to
be lowest antibiotic in that second
panel
no come so
similarly the model predicts that
population structure imposed by any
random combination of these drug
concentration and entirely account with
the emergence of trance continues in
other words the model says that whatever
effect the drugs have on the parents
whatever that product is so will the
transcontinent Paulo it will accurately
predict the emergence
and so we tested this use a fake
different combination four of which were
on that previous slide and we expanded
that to include some additional drugs
other directions of transfer and
including up to six time points up until
the time point I showed you on that
preview that previous flies
and we could show that as before the
experiments validated modeling
prediction and the population structure
and posed by the drug is associated to
predict the transcontinent emergence
and so now that our model accurately
predicts our biology you can ask some
new questions that are potentially more
interesting and we don't necessarily
know the answer to get in a hopes of
generating some useful insights
for example since population structure
that tapes sense conjugate emergence 10
effective building strategies be used to
preemptively minimize trans conjugates
by controlling that population structure
for using the same model we implemented
different dosing schemes by varying the
delivering profile of one or multiple
drugs
so here on the Left I'm showing just two
examples where first and alternating the
drugs crunch elite and second I'm
introducing both drugs concurrently and
if you look at the modeling predictions
on the right you can see that depending
on how we deliver the drugs this has a
drastic influence over the outcome on
the selection poor chance conjugates
and so overall this modeling analysis
suggests
nul insights which is that there's a lot
of room to optimize the way we deliver
drugs to take advantage of these eco evo
dynamics
minimize the emergence of trans
countries
you
but as I'm sure pretty much anybody
watching this is thinking this model is
far from realistic since nature is far
more complex consisting of diverse
bacterial species connected through a
very intricate web of gene exchange this
is actually particularly relevant for
the human microbiome which is known to
be a hotspot for horizontal gene
transfer anastagia be a reservoir by
which pathogens that you come into
contact with can acquire resistance
through HTTP
so to begin bridging this gap between
our test model in reality and to start
addressing this question of how HDPE
contributes the plasmon persistence I
reformulated the model slightly to make
it general you'll see instead of the
three populations I had before which was
useful for validation purposes now in
investigating only a single population
but either does or does not have the
plasmid and so this means that I can
start to easily and rapidly increase the
complexity by sort of stitching together
connecting any number of these models
each parallel to one another to generate
multi-dimensional models that have n
number of species and P number of
plasmids so as many pieces and plasmids
that we want
and just to note to maintain relevance
i've also included that the population
can lose the plasmid due to what's
called the natural plasmid loss rate and
that's just the error associated with
every time a cell divides one of the
daughter cells don't carry that plasmid
i've also included the region which just
allows us to maintain longer periods of
continuous growth so that we can start
to investigate these very long-term
evolutionary consequences
an important aspect of these changes is
that I can now solve an analytical
solution of these equations this is
particularly useful to gain relevant
insights into specific parameters that
may be more dominant than others
during conjugation and potentially
during plasma persistence in this case
I have an actual criteria that describes
the transition between plasmid existence
and plasmid elimination in other words
the model states that there exists a
critical conjugation efficiency a
critical rate of conjugation
vista plans on your plasmid cost and a+
lacerate
natural conjugation rate is above this
critical conjugation
in the plasmid will persist
summarize that idea to put that another
way the model predicts that this
conjugation is sufficiently fast then
the plasmid can be maintained despite a
potentially significant cost to the host
the plus is experimental ease
with the simplest case of a single
species and a single costly plasmid now
I examined the long-term plasma dynamics
of a conjugation plasmid compared to a
non transferable control conjugation
present so this was in 10 MP transfers
but since the cost of the control
plasmid is identical to that of the
conjugation plasmid then when I compare
the two experiments side by side any
differences that arise are specifically
attributed to that of conjugation of
horizontal gene fences
first I'm showing you the long-term
dynamics of a costly plasmid
within without conjugation and
at the Plaza dynamics in the presence of
an antibiotic an antibiotic that
specifically selects for a resistance on
this plasma and this is a positive
control because we should be selecting
for the present population whether that
plasmid can conjugate or not so starting
on the left hand side of the break down
the center of this slide to the two
figures on the left hand side under no
conjugation the x axis is gays and the y
axis is the percent or the fraction of
cells
the blue line is cells the population
without a plasmid the orange is I'll put
the plasmid and as expected you can see
that in the presence of the antibiotic
that plasmid is dominated selected for
this is validated using modeling and
experiments when you compare that with
the right hand side and the presence of
contribution it doesn't matter whether
or not that process and conjugate
collection favors the persistence or the
dominance of that costly plasmid and it
does that regardless of conjugation
in the absence of antibiotics without
conjugation
Modelling predicts and experiments
confirm the competition and natural
plasmon law favors the elimination of
the presence
this next sense the plasmid is costly
look at the left-hand side under no
conjugation you can see that that orange
line is out computed and the blue line
kicked over so the plasma is eliminated
conjugation sight through competition
which is exactly the idea of reversing
resistance
now when you compare that to the right
hand side the figures under with
conjugation you can see that the results
are flipped
you can see that despite the fact that
the costly plasmid is out completed
without conjugation simply being able to
conjugate enables that plasma to
dominate and persist throughout the
duration of this experiment as if they
were being selected for by an
antibiotics to go again that's on the
right-hand side here the bottom row the
orange line dominates the plasmid the
figure compared to the left-hand side
bottom row where the orange line is
appreciated promised we can conclude
that while we might be able to reverse
resistance in the absence of antibiotics
like on the left-hand side conjugation
is sufficiently fast to present to
prevent that from happening even for
coffee plasmas at least under these
positions
and so given the general framework of
this model you can now start to slowly
increase the complexity and see how well
our formulation captures these financial
data
so I'm first showing you the extension
to a two species with a single plasmid
and again if you look at those same
panels as before experiments validated
Nottoli for the costly plasmon was
eliminated from competition in the
absence of conjugation on the left-hand
side bottom row however in the presence
of conjugation the plasma could be
transferred so fast that it overcomes
the disadvantage of being costly and it
is capable of persisting based on
conjugation alone
the model holds for two plasmas and a
single species so long as the plasmas
are compatible and they don't
drastically interfere with the
conjugation efficiencies
both plasmas can be maintained in
absence of notes of erotic due to
conjugation alone
to say one-third through those come on
quickly so that I could get to this one
because it's pretty much summarizes
everything the last set of exponents
examine these are three species and
three partners
and it's in the left hand side without
any conjugation without any pauses one
species dominance
this year the figures are showing days
on the x-axis and fraction of the
population on the y-axis you can see the
shading represents the fraction of the
population and the yellow population is
obviously the most fit which is based on
our birth rates
and when you compare it to the right
hand side when we have all six
populations and the starting conditions
you can see that all plasmas and species
persist and coexist
suggesting generality of our assignments
in our models assistance of far greater
complexity
now how predictive is that criterion
that I said I said obviously that is
true for this particular system
about natural plasmas right now I've
been using synthetic system
to demonstrate the potential utility of
this plasmid existent criterion I
identified a panel of nine native
plasmids that I showed earlier please
cover most of the common plasmid
compatibility groups and they include
several plasmid from clinical isolates
through our collaboration with a Duke
Medical Center that express extended
extended spectrum beta-lactam aces which
is a which are a huge clinical concern
and I calculated the critical
conjugation efficiency that I'm showing
you on the left so this is based on the
model using the criteria the model
predicts and all of these classes will
persist through conjugation adjectives
in the synthetic system
and indeed experiments upheld the
modeling predictions which speaks to the
strength in the model and parameter
estimation to suggest the results are
not specific to a synthetic system and
conjugation can facilitate the
persistence of natural plasma Institute
now unfortunately these data outline a
fairly negative narrative which is that
conjugation can be sufficiently fast to
maintain plasmids despite a potentially
high cost
and it's not true this suggests that
even if we were to discontinue all
antibiotics we may never actually be
able to sufficiently reverse resistance
but with high confidence in the model it
gives us high confidence to look into
which parameters or potential
therapeutic targets
of interest would be those that
facilitate destabilizing the plastics or
in other words can we gain any insights
from understanding the dynamics any
better based on the criteria the model
suggests that simultaneously reducing
conjugation rates and promoting plasmid
error rates
we'll potentially destabilize the
plasmid
the time synergistically overturn the
criterion and theoretically reverse
resistance
so using compounds that I identified
from the literature that target these
two processes
I verified that they did in fact work as
a potential strategy on the right hand
side of this slide the x-axis again is
days and the y-axis is the fraction of a
clinical ESBL plasmus and you can see
that in the presence of both of these
compounds if we inhibit conjugation and
promote plasmid loss we can
synergistically overturn and reverse
resistance
now in my very last data slide to
demonstrate the sole generality of these
modeling insights I'm showing you here
at the same panel of relevant plasmids
here I reactivated the parameters and
the presence of both of these compounds
and I recalculated that critical
conjugation efficiency to see what it
would predict
for four of these plasmas the model
predicted that we could completely
reverse the plasma persistence those
four I just highlighted in red with red
dots over the bars
very mentally I validated that indeed
these four plasmas were sufficiently
reversed in the presence of both of
these contents
now for the remaining size the model
predicted that although the chemicals
could not overturn the criterion
entirely they would reduce the plasma
dominance to varying degrees and in all
cases we could reduce the spread of
resistance compared to the non treated
versions but we could not entirely
reverse it
so to summarize horizontal view transfer
is a dominant mechanism responsible for
the rapid and global spread of
antibiotic resistance primarily through
the conjugation of plasmids
disability for bacteria to rapidly adapt
result in complex ecological and
evolutionary dynamics
models are a potential tool to
facilitate understanding complex
bacterial dynamics but in order to be
useful accurate and rigorous parameter
estimates are required from meaningful
model predictions external validation
and finally modeling can provide useful
biological insights that can be used to
generate hypotheses to guide future
experiments then I potentially have
clinical relevance in fact we did file a
provisional patent on a combination of
these two compounds and we're hoping to
screen and identify other chemicals and
similar activity but greater efficacy to
get at those final plasmids that we
could not reverse and think about it as
a potential preventative measures and
with that I want to think specifically
most of this work was done at Duke
University under a in the lab of dr. Lin
Chen Yu and Shu Xiang Liang developed a
microfluidic platform where that movie
was taken and thank everybody for tuning
in and listening and inhabit answer any
questions either now or after after this
is done so thank you thank you dr. Lu
petka for that informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email let's get started our first
question is what is the time scale for
physical transfer of a plasmid
sure
so it takes about 100 minutes to
transfer the entire eco lights genome
through conjugation that's about 4
million bases
about 40 kV can be transferred per
minute which means a large conjugation
plasmon will be transferred in well
under five minutes and some and under
one how similar are in vitro and in vivo
estimates of conjugation efficiency
yeah that's a great question so it is
difficult to get an estimate on the
conjugation efficiency itself in vivo
for the reasons I outlined in the
presentation because we don't have a
good control over those assumptions we
need although new methods are coming out
to do just that presumably if we could
we could pitch elate the physiological
states in vitro the rate constant itself
would not necessarily change what does
change in vivo is the chance for
frequency and see microbiome density and
diversity creates species and other
ecological barriers there may not be an
accessible pool of recipients that are
immediately proximal and conjugation
relies on contact immediate proximity
certain perturbations can create
scenarios with greater likelihood for
context actually for example one study
showed that inflammation in the bowel
can create balloons of E coli and
Salmonella and they got and they could
they could reach up to 100 in efficiency
and now is similar to the in vitro
resonance thank you thank you okay we
have time for just one more question
why is alternating dosing more effective
and does this depend on the frequency of
drug delivery
yeah another great question alternating
dosing takes advantage of the idea that
the population structure dictates can't
conjugate emergence
since the product donor times recipient
is actually predictor of the trans
conjugating merchants from those
modeling results
creating or designing those things such
that it minimizes the favorable ratio
between those two populations will
minimize the number of number of
contribution events so that we can
minimize the emergence of Trance
countries
great I would like to once again thank
dr. Lopez where you finish with that by
the way just want to make sure oh yeah
okay great well I want to thank you
again for your presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
13 2018 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye